mariana se está entrenando para
participar en una carrera su podómetro
marca en cuantos kilómetros corrió cada
día y a continuación se muestra la
información guardada por el podómetro en
los últimos cuatro días
ok aquí está cuánto corrió cada día de
sábado a martes y nos dicen estimar
cuántos kilómetros corrió en total los
últimos cuatro días y después calcula la
cantidad exacta ok lo que vamos a hacer
nosotros para estimar cuántos kilómetros
corrió es redondear estos números a las
unidades y después sumar estas
aproximaciones entonces el sábado que
mariana corrió 3.89 km
redondeando como el 8 es mayor o igual
que el 5 vamos a redondear este número
hacia arriba o sea que nos va a quedar
que mariana corrió aproximadamente el
sábado 4 kilómetros ahora el domingo
redondeando al nivel de las unidades
como el 1 es estrictamente menor que el
5 vamos a redondear hacia abajo en el
domingo nos va a quedar
mente 5 km del lunes 2 también es
estrictamente menor que el 5
entonces redondeamos hacia abajo y nos
queda que es aproximadamente 10 km del
martes 3.35 como el 3 es menor que el 50
donde hacia abajo y nos quedan 3
kilómetros y ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer para estimar cuántos kilómetros
corrió en total los últimos 4 días es
sumar estas cantidades 45 son 9 + 10 19
unas 322 entonces mariana corrió
aproximadamente 22 kilómetros ahora lo
que tenemos que hacer es calcular la
cantidad exacta de kilómetros así es que
tenemos que sumar estos números entonces
3.89 más 5.1 y algo que siempre tenemos
que recordar cuando estemos sumando
números que tienen parte decimal es que
siempre hay que
el punto decimal ok y ahora vamos a
sumar los kilómetros que corrió maría en
el lunes
entonces ponemos primero el punto
decimal luego la parte de email y luego
los enteros y el martes corrió 3.35
kilómetros ahora sí vamos a hacer la
suma 9 +1 10 5 15 y llevamos 11 + 89 más
110 más 2 12 y más 3 15 o sea que
ponemos por aquí el 5 y llevamos 1 otra
cosa que nunca que olvidar es poner el
punto decimal en su lugar y seguimos
sumando 13 4 5 9 10 19 más 3 22 20 2
osea que mariana corrió exactamente
22.55 kilómetros entonces esta fue una
muy buena aproximación porque nada más
perdimos puntos
55 km